let's play a hypothetical situation and
the last thing we'll talk about with
russia um
twelve percent of global oil production
in the country and they just decide
we're not gonna sell it in dollars
anymore we're gonna price it in bitcoin
what happens
are we like literally dropping bombs in
uh uh moscow tomorrow like wha what do
we do i think bitcoiners would become
extremely reviled in this country
more so than we are already we'd be
accused of being russian stooges
probably i mean
and by the way we're laughing but
literally online people who are saying
hey hold on a second and questioning or
asking uh for more thoughtful analysis
of the situation i've already seen
people being accused of being uh russian
assets
yeah i saw take today saying like
bitcoin facilitates war or encourages
war it's like what kind of world are
these people living in
all right so so if that was to occur
there would obviously be uh
some portion of the uh political regime
in the united states who would say
you're holding an asset that they're
pricing their assets and their oil in we
don't like you
fine
what's the geopolitical ramifications i
mean all the times the us has gone after
some dictator militarily in the last uh
20 30 years has been because they've
tried to price their commodities in
something other than us dollars
whether it's saddam whether it's gaddafi
um i always use those two as the example
like there's two guys recently who tried
to do it and they're dead yeah they buy
up by u.s hands yeah chavez tried we
didn't succeed there but uh yeah i mean
it's not a coincidence right
uh there's no other real explanation for
the iraq war frankly
is there um
is it fair to compare
uh
those three that you just mentioned with
putin
they didn't have the leverage that he
has he feels like he has leverage but he
also feels um well he does have leverage
that's what i'm saying he feels like he
has more leverage but but also uh it
feels like um
it's a different type of country he's
more defense mechanisms of nuclear
weapons like it's just very different
scenario he's more deliberate and yeah
he they are a nuclear
nation they have more nuclear warheads
than the us does we don't really have an
ability to
interfere with them
that much i mean we haven't
for you know what 70 80 years now
do you think it's likely they do this i
don't think so i think there's a lot of
brinksmanship here and i think people
are addicted to the soap opera and you
know they just see life through like as
if it's like an hbo series or something
uh but you know and maybe putin will
extract some some territorial gains from
the ukraine but no i do not think we see
full-fledged warfare here i'll put that
on the record yeah i i tend to agree
with you that that that's very hard uh
both it's hard to see from a
u.s citizen's appetite for that right
just in terms of like the
especially again there's an election
coming up right and so uh uh that feels
um in the past maybe going to war would
provide for uh an ability to rally and
unite citizens and use that as a
leverage point for an election it feels
like it would have the opposite effect
now um and would almost guarantee that
uh the the um the current administration
would lose uh control but also it feels
like uh
syria is always like one of my favorite
ones to point out like
are we at war with syria we keep
dropping bombs over there and killing
people and doing all stuff and like by
the way there's some bad people right
and like so it's not discounting what
some people have done et cetera but like
why do we do that why can't we do that
well it's because like what are they
gonna do it's kind of the the response
right there's like an american
imperialism or arrogance that comes uh
with it
i don't think you can do that in russia
like if we go and we drop bombs in
russia like i i would be worried but
yeah you can't not against the nuclear
you know regional power like that and a
lot of people think this can be like
iraq where bush's approval rating
skyrocketed 95 after that no this is
going to be like the soviet union
invading afghanistan to try and regain
some credibility as the regime was
crumbling yeah that's the equivalent of
this yeah i i didn't agree so so uh
i think we see eye to eye john do you
think there's gonna be war like actual
violent
no i
no i don't think so it's on the table
for sure but i think it's going to be a
lot of bark no bite and if the bite is
they're going to annex part of the
ukraine a little bit um take some
territorial stuff but i don't think
they're gonna like get off the us dollar
within the next year yeah um
[Music]
i think that there's a higher
probability of them pricing oil in
something other than a dollar not
necessarily bitcoin but something other
than the dollar but what i don't think
is going to happen is it's going to be
like a uh
press a button 100 of all of our oil all
in this new currency that we've chosen
uh and we're never going to use dollars
again i actually think what becomes uh
el salvador strategy like oh we pricing
dollars end right it's not either or
it's an and type situation
and it just normalizes and like to your
point about the deliberate nature
how do you get mad what's priced in
dollars and
rubles yeah you want you know whatever
currency bitcoin whatever um
but that does feel like that would be
another kind of milestone moment of the
geopolitical you know kind of chess
match of like
i think every political leader in the
world knows like that's the thing that
the that that when you poke the bear
all hell comes down right and we've seen
example after example of it and
if you really if you really want to take
a you know kind of move your chest piece
forward
like there's what you go into ukraine
right uh you stop exporting your oil uh
and kind of cause chaos around the world
you price your oil in a different
currency there's maybe like six or seven
things we'd come up with that you could
do
they're already doing some of them right
so like what else is left uh i don't
know it's a gradual thing you don't exit
um you know a global reserve currency
immediately you can't do that they are
very sticky you know the for instance
the uk
stopped being a global power capable of
projecting power and you know after
world war one the british pound was a
global reserve currency until around the
40s
so the currency is often the last thing
that um exits stage left after an empire
has lost power and control
so it might be the case that the dollar
atlas outlasts the u.s empire yeah right
the dollar might be the stickiest thing
yeah but yeah you can't get rid of it
overnight